grow cameras please bro
watching steven spielberg start filming
and turning and saying
i am terrified was a great place for all
of us to start
at one point attorney said it's like
action movies and it's really true
activating a musical number is key
that's where we cut
that's the cut the artistry of jansen
the gym is justin peck and his assistant
choreographers what they did i watched
it go up on its feet in the rehearsal
halls so i watched it evolving into
something very special and very
different than any other production of
west side story my approach to creating
this for film was to choreograph a
number from start to finish i wanted the
performers to be able to experience a
sense of what the entire construction of
a particular number
would be
is his own choreographer and he has a
very specific style which i will tell
you it's very hard to conjure out of
your body but
it's beautiful
approaching a musical it really requires
like developing some new techniques and
it was a very steep learning curve and
steven just learned it i've never
rehearsed the way we rehearsed on west
side story four months of rehearsals
maybe even longer than that it gave me a
chance to figure out how to put my
camera to all the dance that was being
designed by justin peck
and so i was coordinating my iphone with
justin's dance steps and i would cut
that together to the music and i would
look at it cut together and i would go
back and reshoot it a second time
finding different ways for the camera to
become a dancer so i was storyboarding
on video and i was storyboarding as i
usually do hand to paper the dance of
the gym could be the movie as far as i'm
concerned on one of the days before
shooting justin and steven just let them
do the whole dance sequence but to see
it live happening was breathtaking
it's a dance-off between puerto ricans
and the jets
who are irish polish italians and a mix
of other cultures and all of a sudden it
gets separated and everyone starts to
show off their skills their culture it
was really great to see the battle going
on between two different styles it's
become more relevant now
than the original west side story
because of what's happening in our times
there's something that is so important
about the race
aspect and the fact that at the end of
the day we're all the human race
the sharks are together the jets are
together it's really the only time in
the movie that they're all working as
one group
we looked at a lot of gems because we
had so many dancers that had to fit in
the space we didn't want it to be
enormous so it had to be intimate enough
to hold the dance but large enough to
work and it needed to have bleachers and
then of course it needed a stage had to
have good entrances for the sharks to
come in because the shark's entrance
into the dance was a big event
[Music]
the dance of the gym was 60 dancer
actors and 150 extras and some very very
ambitious shots that involved a lot of
people a lot of moving parts and
oftentimes took a long time to capture
every time you deal with a whole bunch
of people in the frame
it's a nightmare for cinematographer
because we wanted to create that sense
of deep focus so that requires
tremendous amount of light this was the
movie that had to be sharp all the way
from the foreground to the background to
reflect the beauty of the story to
reflect the beauty of the dance
[Applause]
we had a lot of discussions with the
wardrobe department as well with paul
there was a color palette for the sharks
and a color palette for the jets
we spent months talking about this and
shopping for it
each of the dresses is different and
they are to be able to hold the gang
together as a group and fabric was
chosen to do just the right thing so
that was engineered so that they will
open up and it would give justin
everything that he needed for the
movement where's paul as well
to be shown the appreciation of the
people that are going to be wearing the
clothes was very very moving paul was
certainly a new kid on the block because
i used so many of the same people over
and over again film after film but i
love paul's work he designed all the
costumes for hamilton and i really
wanted to work with him on this
[Music]
with stephen's help with the help of the
entire creative team and tony kushner
like i've been able to find something
really new inside of her and who this
character is
at the end of dance in the gym i
couldn't believe i was never going back
to that high school i would never see
that gym again it was so sad he remains
a student he remains curious and when
he's not working he tells me he's just
studying footage here's a guy who just
loves what he does and you know that
really was infectious for everyone it
allowed everyone to kind of come and
approach the material from the same
mentality of
just chasing your joy we had a blast it
was early in the schedule and dance in
the gym help us realize the kind of
movie we were making this is the end of
dancing
i love it that's fantastic america goes
to a lot of different places he saw it
in the script and talked about oh my
goodness america is a challenge it
starts in the apartment but then it goes
and travels through the entire
neighborhood so we had a series of large
street sets
[Music]
took 10 days to shoot america and there
was a heat wave it just became part of
the feel part of the character of the
song to have to perform this very
vibrant empowering song when it's like
hot sweltering summer day
[Music]
it's always an added challenge when
you're on location but my goal is always
to make it sound real
whenever you're doing a live piece of
music you have to use wireless earpieces
they do pre-records before we're doing a
scene and those pre-records will play
back into their ear pieces when we start
filming we'll do a few pieces to play
back so the actors get into it and then
we'll switch over and go to live oh
that's great andy nelson and gary
ridestrom are more concerned about
really getting as many sound effects
about getting the best vocal tracks
possible so jerry and mike and with
everybody who work with me they would
put microphones all over the place and
we would capture cars cranes and
everything else that was going on while
we're doing dialogue so the tracks have
a lot going on
we got it great
i basically said i'm not telling the
story unless every shark can be from the
latinx community i don't want to do
what's been done on every stage
production that's ever been mounted
which is basically to just mix and match
i wanted this to be an all-latinx cast
we have out of 50 cast members 20 are
new york ricans or puerto ricans or
descendants from puerto rico so i did as
much as i could christy mccosko did as
much as she could and cindy told the
casting director and certainly tony
kushner to marshall this edict and never
break that rule and we didn't and better
get rid of your accent
one of the gifts this movie has brought
me is
is the gift of acceptance of who i am
[Music]
and to be accepted by
the latin community by the hispanic
community and more importantly by the
puerto rican community it's something i
never really thought i was going to find
it's rather difficult to go on the
brightly lit streets at noon with hot
harsh light having dancers and making it
glossy
you have that bright top light you get
big shadows in people's faces so you end
up bringing many big lights and you've
got 100 degree weather and then you're
bringing lights that increase the
temperature under twenty so you have to
think of that
the third day got so bad that we had to
cancel the shoot
oh it was very hot it was so hot
but it was an incredible experience you
see people looking outside their windows
it was very fun and i wouldn't trade it
for the world making this film outside
in the streets of new york it culminates
in this massive intersection it's almost
like old hollywood moment
[Music]
the whole point of ending america with a
kiss is because no matter how different
they view this world
that kiss brings them together
[Music]
amazing yeah
you